we want to reward Behavior like
initiative but very often we only reward
output performance I'll give you one
simple example so I was young in my
career I worked for a large Ad Agency a
large marketing firm and we had a big
new business pitch in the New Year this
was December and uh what was traditional
is all the senior Executives would do
the business pitch but it was Christmas
time so they all went on their vacations
and me and one other Junior person were
left back at the office and they told us
prepare the War Room for when they get
back so they can do the pitch which
basically means hang the research on the
walls Well that took an hour and we
still had a week and so we decided to do
the pitch ourselves which is we went
through all the research we went we comb
through it we found some insights and we
wrote the deck we wrote the pitch deck
and when the executives came back we
presented our work and they used Our
Deck in the pitch which was amazing they
actually used our strategy and we lost
the business we didn't win the pitch and
I got a huge promotion my boss promoted
me two levels up I skipped a level
because he wasn't rewarding my
performance he was rewarding my behavior
because he saw the initiative that I
took and he wanted more of that so I
think uh that's a a large part of it as
well if you want Innovation you have to
reward the kinds of behavior that begets
Innovation but if we only reward output
all you're going to get is people taking
safe roads because they want the output
so I think you have to you have to
recognize the reward the kind of
behaviors that you want one